godspeed eagle
this is a very big production we're
starting in 1969 but we're actually
spanning out to 1974 and just in the
first season control how much fuel does
you have left twenty seconds flight we
are recreating something that really did
exist we're recreating NASA it's very
surreal to be working on the show where
you're working almost in three worlds
you're working on earth in Houston Texas
you're in space and we're on the moon on
the lunar surface the show kind of
shifts between those three worlds we are
standing in Mission Control set which is
an exact replica of the original Mission
Control at NASA circa 1969 our
compartment has made this to the square
handsome the attention to detail is
unbelievable the accuracy is incredible
especially in Mission Control the hinges
on the door the color of the paint
depends on the desks it's perfect down
to the smallest detail
the depth of the research that it takes
to sort of pull that stuff together is
really exciting even I'm surprised at
how good the sets look it's the set
dressing
it's the props in our show props are
such a key thing so when you're walking
through that room every flight plan on
the desk at a console is a real flight
plan
I remember our prop master Jamie once
came in really excited because he was
like we got a wrench that is the actual
wrench that they used on an Apollo
mission it's like that's the level of
detail that they hit we wanted to make
sure that we were 100 percent accurate a
great importance was put on how accurate
everything was to the time period it's
really important to the actors that they
have a physical object that they can
interact with that helps them come into
their character the level of
authenticity at every single level from
wardrobe to set to the period detail of
makeup everything it all contributes and
it's not arbitrary
it's very helpful for your performance
because you step into this world that is
very meticulously built and it just
feels truthful and it just feels right
anytime actors and walk on this stage
that looks like real life I think it
helps transport them into the characters
you really feel like you're transported
to the 60s
Jill our costume designer is one of our
key storytellers costume really does
tell a story it tells you who the
characters are where they've come from
and sometimes even where they're going
Ron Moore really wanted this to feel
like middle america like houston we
really wanted to capture that so it
became a lot of research and what was
interesting for me when I started
researching the 60s is so much of the
sixties research is in black and white
so it got very tricky to kind of put
together a color palette and that's when
I went to the Sears catalogs which were
really perfect for this show because
that's middle America they really gave a
range of everything from housewife to
suits for secretaries and schoolteachers
I think that this will resonate with a
lot of people
[Music]
I love the detail and the sets I love
walking onto the sets and just losing
myself kind of takes you back to where
all these things took place the true
collaboration because in a writers room
you can say anything and we've said a
lot of things we were very ambitious
seeing what they've been able to pull
off from the production design to the
costumes to props it's been incredible
we got the best seat in the house
you